(audience applauding)
(Oliver cheering)
- Yup, yup, yup.
I'm gonna lead.
(audience cheering)
There's a lot of fans here.
- Yeah.
- Thank you, thank you.
- I don't know if y'all
saw "That's My Jam"
with miss over here.
- [Kate] Oh, my gosh.
- [Kelly] But I was
like, we're competitive.
so I love that.
I'm very competitive.
- Am I competitive?
- Yes.
- Oh no, yeah
(audience laughing)
A person that asks that
is totally competitive.
- Very.
- I literally-
- She's the one screaming
in game nights and stuff.
- Yes.
- I mean, she's the one who's,
I'm like, "Kate, it's a game night.
"We're supposed have a good time.
- [Kate] I'm like, "Shut up!"
- I know.
(Audience laughing)
- So Oliver...
- Accusations of cheating all the time.
- After the Jimmy Fallon thing
I literally called Ollie,
I'm like, "Was I nuts?
"Did I come across like too competitive?"
- This is exactly what I
asked my friends about me
when I was on the show.
I was like, "Do I come across as insane?
- Yeah, because something happens.
- [Kelly] Yeah, me too.
- And I'm just like, get me in it!
- [Oliver] Yeah
- And it takes you over completely.
- Yes, but why play unless
you're gonna compete?
- That's what I say.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Look at him, he's out.
- You show up to win.
(cross-talking) Like its
the end of the world.
- Kate's had game nights forever, right?
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- First of all I never get invited.
- Wait, is that because...
- It's actually true.
- Yeah, because I'm not
a big enough celebrity
is what I think
(all laughing)
- I really do, because--
- That's not true, no, that's no.
- She's like "owkay"
- Oh wait, is it because
you're not competitive enough?
- No, no, no, it's because I have fear
when I'm going up against
Leo DiCaprio and Tom Hanks,
and to, you know
- No, No and Oliver
- and like, you know
- That's ridiculous.
- No, it's true.
Like Sir Anthony Hopkins doing
running charades
- What?
(Kate laughing)
- I would never wanna play
charades in that company.
- I would get anything for
Sir Anthony Hopkins to do
- No, but I'm, I'm serious in that.
Like I have anxiety for
game nights because she
invites very prominent people
who are professionals.
- No
No, No stop.
- Academy Award winners.
- No, here's the thing.
- I wouldn't go either
- The truth is that
I used to invite him
and he never showed up.
- No.
So then I just
stopped inviting him.
- Yeah.
- Because he'd never, well,
first of all
your wife is always so late.
- I know
- with the party would
be like done.
( Kelly claps)
- I know
- It's true, Erin.
You're like, it's the kid's birthday.
It's five thirty.
And like, literally it's like 8:00 PM.
I'm like, Erin?
(Laughing)
- Are you? Where are the kids?
She's like, no, no, we're in the car.
We're in the car.
- Those are people. That's a thing.
Like some people don't do
well at time management.
What?
- No, I know
- I'm not late for a game night
and I'm not late for a game.
No, I'm not late for like a gig.
No, I would never those
people that wait, I don't
know why fans do that.
Three hours later, the
artist gets on stage.
I'm like, it's terrible.
I'm at like Waffle House
- By then. Like I'm at
like, I'm like gone by then.
- No, I, I now I want to have
a game night with you.
(Crowd cheering)
- Oh my you, I dunno if people
- You have to do it
- I get, I get crazy.
Here's the thing.
I'm not a sore loser.
That's not it.
I don't care if I lose
but I don't want to play with
people that, that don't--
- Wanna play play.
- You can't get outta here.
- I can't stand
- I get that.
Of course.
- And then they make you feel
bad that you're competitive.
- Yeah but when its, but
when it's like Christmas Eve
and we're playing game out
with the family and all of
a sudden everyone's screaming
at each other, like you cheated.
And of course mom, has left
the room 30 minutes ago.
She's like, I'm not
dealing with any of this.
She's gone.
You can see mom's face.
When we all decide to play a game.
It's like--
- That's my mother.
- Yeah. It's like, no
- My mother cannot stand
because me and my sister are like, we
we don't play with cheaters either.
- Yeah.
- You are kicked out.
We actually, my sister and I on tour
we didn't allow Dennis
our tour manager to play
Yahtzee with us again
- because he cheats.
- No, because he didn't get
excited about his freaking Yahtzee.
- Oh,
- He got a Yahtzee
and he just was like
he literally went, "Oh Yahtzee."
And I was like, no
- No
- I was like, what?
- You're banned.
- He got kicked off.
- The word is designed for
you to scream it.
- Yes
Like YAHTZEE!
- It's exciting.
- Oh, Yahtzee is the best.
It's exciting.
(Crosstalk)
- That was my second
- I like, what's
like your game of choice?
- Well, game night is usually mafia.
Do you know mafia?
No. It's like, woo
- wait.
It's like where will
- Everyone dead at the end?
It's...
(Laughing)
- Well
- Pretty much.
Pretty much.
Except Tom Hanks.
- Yeah. He always wins
- Tom Hanks.
Nobody wants to kill Tom Hanks.
- No, you're right.
This is weird.
- I'm not kidding.
No, no, no.
It's like, oh
- My, so here.
So mafia
- okay.
Is a game that was act.
There's a, the it's the English version is
called where wolfs and villagers.
And it was apparently I could
be totally wrong created
by the MI6 to see how
sociopathic you are at lie.
Right. It it's basically like if you're
if you can convince
somebody and lie that well
then you're on like a good
path to being a spot, you know?
- Wow.
- But see you play with a lot of actors.
This must be hard.
- I wasn't really keen.
- You
- Were
- I'm intimidated
very seriously.
- And
- It's all of a sudden
Leo was looking at me.
He's like, (Laughing)
What do I do?
I'm freaking out.
- And I'm like, Tom Hanks what do I do?
It's an audition. You don't wanna fail.
- I will always be busy
if you ever invite me.
I'm terrified of that.
Like around actors.
- No, it's so much fun.
It, it really is so much fun.
And, and the thing, the
only, I would never do it
with a partner.
I think it's broken up
most of my partnerships
( Kate laughs)
- I get into, how did you kill me?
I can't believe you just killed me.
- I am you, you know, playing a game.
- Yeah. And then, you
know, you're in a game.
It's like, if they're
doing something wrong
and even if you're on the
same team and you know
you have to kill them, you're like
I gotta kill my, I gotta kill 'them.
Oh yeah.
And, and it's over the it's
like, it really gets personal.
That's happened a couple
times a game night.
- Okay.
- Yeah, like people have left early.
- Yeah. I don't do well
with subjective games in crowds, like
with my games with subjective.
- You'd be great. And you'd be loud.
I could tell you.
- I know.
- And it would happen.
It would just all of a sudden
like halfway through, you'd
be like, I know you're mafia!
- Like, wait, here's a good example
of how I play games.
So I did Hollywood Name Night
and Isla Fisher was on my team
and this is how crazy I get.
She literally being a girl's
girl, like leaned over to me
and she was like, "Hey, just let you know
like maybe you wanna
like, not drink anymore."
And I was like, "Oh, I..."
( Kate laughing)
- Not Drink.
- "This is, this is not alcohol man."
- You're like, you're like,
- I literally, we were on camera
So I was like fake drinking.
I was like, not really drinking.
And I was like
- Oh, this is just like, who I am.
I was like, this is not,
this is not alcohol.
- You were like, We
won't, we're not friends.
I was like, I was like, she thinks
- I'm too much.
I am.
But I like playing games anyway.
And that's about me and my craziness.
- Your new podcast is
from sibling revelry.
- So tell us more
about the podcast.
Like what happens and
why did you wanna do it?
- You know, we, we really,
it kind of just came
from us saying like,
we should do a podcast.
- Yeah. I was like that simple.
- Were y'all close,
growing up?
Like, is this what, what
- Yeah, well, no.
I mean the, that
- No, we weren't.
- We weren't, I
- Mean, we were closed
by proximity, you know
obviously it's like, we are really
- I think that's what makes
the podcast nice because there
we do revere each other
now, but back in the day
we were going through
some stuff and
- That sisters and brothers
- Well, what's interesting is that
since we've been interviewing
so many siblings, we realize
that a lot of times we're
sort of like, I'm like
why weren't you like
that when we were kids?
Like, they're so nice.
- Yeah. And then I'm like,
why aren't you like this now?
(Oliver claps)
(crowd cheering)
I have an excuse.
I was eight.
- What's your excuse, we're in our 40s?
- What are your reason now?
- How much therapy should--
- No, but it's really a special show
for us because it started as
us wanting to work together
and do something.
Siblings was the obvious thing.
- Yeah.
- It's an under-explored
relationship I think.
And, and really when
siblings are together more
than when we are with
our parents, you know,
- I mean that's what all we have.
- Yeah. And, and we, we lean on each other
and we fight and there's
all kinds of dynamics.
And we want to get that.
- I tell my kids this, but because,
I was a child divorce.
They are too y'all are as well.
Yeah. Yeah.
But I tell my kids this
I'm I keep saying to them
I'm like quit fighting amongst each other.
They're 22 months apart.
I'm like, you're each,
other's like buddy for life.
Yeah. Like if you're gonna
get mad, get mad at me.
- Yeah. It's funny because
these relationships, siblings
and the whole family dynamic,
they define who we are
you know?
And as we grow up, you kind
of are either looking to sort
of separate yourself from
whatever that dynamic is
and try to sort of pave your own way.
- Because you're finding out
- How you are
- Or you're trying to continue
to nurture those relationships.
And so when we talked to
all these different people,
the common denominator of all
of it is everyone wants to
feel loved by their sibling.
- Um Hmm
- Absolutely.
- And you know?
Yeah. And some people aren't really
able to get there.
They aren't really able
to have that like close
connection based
on where they were raised,
what the divorce situation was
- And how it affected each child.
- So
- Specialists on, like,
we had someone on estrangement,
you know,
on sibling estrangement
- Yeah
which is really an interesting topic
- Which something that
we know a lot about.
- Yeah.
- You know, and with our father, but,
and then we had a twin expert.
Oh yeah.
That's right.
No. Wow.
Can I tell you something?
- What?
- When you sang that
song on 'American idol',
- Oh, sorry.
- I lost it.
- I was pregnant.
- I lost it with you.
- But it does with you,
but becoming the...
Exactly.
You know it,
- yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, no, you know, what's
interesting though
that dynamic is I,
everything changed whenever
I became a mom, because
then I realized the gravity
of the situation and that's
where that song came from.
'Cause I was a, like, you know,
I accepted a lot of things.
You work through things.
And then when you come, you're like
how could you leave your, I would never
- Leave my kids.
- No, I know.
- It's crazy.
- You know, but you know,
then you have to do that.
And then you have to get to the...
then you have to start
looking at that, you know,
forgiveness
- Their life, why they're
like they are and...
- Talk about repairing,
like what that mean.
And is it possible?
Is it not?
I mean, it's just
you know, we, sometimes
it isn't, sometimes
- It isn't, sometimes it isn't
- sometimes, it isn't.
- You know, and then sometimes,
you know, it's really
important to repair because
that's gonna, you know
it's there
it's available and it, you know, and
- that's different for each child.
Yeah. Then my sister and my brother
and I all experience the divorce
of our family, very different
- You know, we found, which
we didn't even realize was how
many people tune in and really feel
like they're able to share
and their stories with us.
- You guys be more open with you
than they are with like
people that are close to them.
Yeah.
- Like these are things we
should be talking about.
Like, that's one thing I think that,
you know, in today's day
and age, like we need
to sort of be looking,
more inward and at the family dynamic,
- Mental Health.
- Oh yeah.
And these things really, even just talking
about it and exploring them and even,
having a sense of humor about
things that are really hard
that, Oliver and I can be
laughing and have a very
dark sense of humor about things.
But at the same time we
cry at like the drop.
Like we can't even get
into our email reads
episodes without balling.
I mean
'Cause we do listen our emails and stuff
and I I'm a total mess.
- Yeah. We're just both...
- Can't use just to take over.
- It's gotta be therapeutic for
although connecting with all those people,
- It is, it is, you know, I think family,
we think family is everything
and this is coming from
a family that is not
perfect.
We're a patchwork family.
- No family is.
- And, and that's the
- That's, it's also fun because
we have deeper conversations.
And it's funny when you have
the mic in front of your face
there's a safety there for some reason.
I don't know why
but I'm able to sort
of express myself
- Even better
- Even better than with when,
when they're, when we're not on.
- Yeah. I'm like
why did this take you like
30 years to express this?
Like on air, like on a yeah.
- Yeah but that's still
not getting anywhere.
Yeah. All I get is well out.
I'm sorry.
You feel that way.